hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
what is your name my dear
I'm Courtney right Courtney right is
back on the channel and is the first
guest of the year
Courtney huh how was your day it was
great that's a good answer yeah a good
day I had a good day too thanks for
asking me I'm good you know you didn't
even give me a chance I wasn't into that
I get that complain a lot I'm
complaining people Courtney I know
through my brother javi Kawai who as of
just a couple days ago has officially
passed a hundred thousand subscribers
few years in the making he's finally
doing it you know I'm always like wait
to catch up older brother Jill get there
soon don't worry you're trailing a
little by little but one day you'll hit
some stride of momentum a whole hundred
I know right might be a little bit more
a long time ago he actually visited the
Aquaman set which surprises me because
of the time he only had 50,000
subscribers gonna make it one day
apparently he had a vlog go up that he
was finally allowed to post it's kind of
a lengthy one I don't think I've ever
watched anything this long from my
brother especially his reactions you
know I got eyes I was looking forward to
it because when he went to that when I
found out he was in Australia on Aquaman
set I was a little pretty jealous I was
pretty jealous too you know I can admit
that I resented him for a while and I
still kind of do but hey that's life
right let's get to it and find out how
exciting was his day uno dos tres a huge
thanks to one of brothers for sponsoring
this video well it's not real we're on a
recreation of Italy here what's what's
this run a fake version of it yeah
around this is like that's I wonder why
what it each it looks like except for
the sides apparently the signs are
deliberately misspelled for Italians who
are watching the movie so they can have
a little chuckle while they watch and
the action sequences there's gonna be a
chase sequence that happens here with
I'm not sure with who but I know it's
gonna be an awesome chase sequence in
the middle of Aquaman with Amanda who's
Amanda this is shouting things at me now
Manta
it's gonna be with man
[Laughter]
[Music]
what is it Jabba Koo am here on the set
of Aquaman Wonder brothers flew myself
and a bunch of youtubers out you can see
them right there in video village
they're all kind of like looking at me
which is nerve-racking they all have way
more subscribers than I do so I'm the
little guy here but right now we're
watching Jason Momoa do a fight scene
one of the things I learned really
quickly is how much of a perfectionist
he is he's trying to get it just right
and learning a lot they're shooting it
in slow-mo so they can like ramp and
stuff like that cuz they're shooting at
48 frames per second as a person who
loves fight scenes it's great to start
out with watching a fight scene being
shot dude it's like so cool he's my
friend Jason he's like flipping his hair
no he doesn't pretty looks pretty sick
doing that kind of thing
[Laughter]
you know who had the vision that you
came through Zac actually asked for me I
was like there's no way they're gonna
have me fat man this is the joke he's
like you know why you're here
oh my god I played one of the bad guys
shoot me some bad guy he goes nope I
watched his character we should play
them I kind of thought maybe the Lobo
like motorcycles job and then he's like
no but just love all aspects of Aquaman
so no I
Wow took me a while to sanding so I was
like blond blond orange drinks he told
me that he wanted to take my tattoos and
put them everywhere kind of you know
dawned on me that super important
obviously to wear Polynesian culture is
a lot of brown skin
hmm I was wondering about this oh we
know I know I've got a devil I was like
let me go how you change a fantastic man
it's been so long yeah are you man how's
the kid okay it was good to see you man
I'm excited like this yeah man I'll tell
you - amen how long have you come for it
look like you're really sore on stage
four of the Aquaman set they showed us
how they do the underwater stuff it's
not actually underwater they're in a
harness and they push the stem in back
and forth so they look like they're
underwater and they have to be able to
simulate that so if I look like wall-e
that's
[Music]
water doing the butterfly hard I have
that same shirt so I keep thinking his
feet
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know like that all day long with
that that works your body like crazy man
like you have to have good abs for that
stuff I felt it I definitely felt it I
think they should introduce that at gyms
as a new exercise because uh they'll get
you know toned really quickly it was all
hamboards this is jade one of the
starters and Aquaman he rig me up in
this thing what was it called again the
tuning for tuning port
now how did you come up with this what
was used on paid a pan okay a long time
ago some of the guys that were rigging
on this rigged on that so they brought
the concept to us okay
and then we've just evolved it with
different heads different applications
of it to suit this film now brutal
honesty how was I on the thing feel good
you might have to get him on board
[Music]
it's just trying to plan your diet which
is it's a whole there's a bunch of
people that figure that I just do what
I'm told trying to look out get ready
it's not like my shirtless scene coming
in on the 15th so I got to get ready for
that whole thing which you can't really
bulk she can't stay really strong
getting from down give you up go down I
don't eat any carbs at all so I can have
beer it's a mess I have to get really
really really really rip that I have to
cut it out for like five days
[Music]
specifically is it EJ it's like all the
fine little details like you can see the
nuanced little things in here it's crazy
like how real it is most of the stuff
you don't even notice when you're
watching the film crop people and the
people who make the sets put such hard
work into it most of this goes unnoticed
I'd love to just look at it and
appreciate it as much as I can like a
tart piece or something if it come here
what action sequence is happening here
apparently a little something awesome
happens with Mira over there
so basically this is post fight thing
yeah he knocks the Bell with Arthur and
Black Manta
[Music]
although who knows when the movie comes
out it could be something totally
different I don't know true things
change all the time it's quickly smart
just spread out the interview have a lot
of conversations with him he came up to
the house kind of geeked out to do
something for my kids we had a lot of
conversations that I was kind of
inspired by him because he recreated the
whole thing so I don't know kind of fall
in footsteps of him we're just watching
him talk about it and get excited I'm
like oh yeah he's a badass he really is
just that he's so pretty so punch what I
know right
oh you wanna fight Superman I look like
it's got a lot of mm-hmm
that's reason why I like it I don't want
to play the good guy and I don't miss
someone play the bad guy if we look back
to other roles that play Drogo was in a
bad guy at all he's actually the most
honest person on that show wins act
first beside me on he was like I want
you to play Outlaw Josey Wales
who wants that Lord we wanted a Western
one of the bad guy who was or if you
wanted a good guy who wasn't afraid to
kill people it's got a base this is an
Atlantian weapons coordinate that's what
you're concentrating a lot of he never
shares elements of nature to inform the
overarching could have designed
aesthetic on film like see these line
work but what we've tried to do on this
film is the terms of using light on the
guns so these guns have all got Wi-Fi
connection oh and we've seen this head
of like a Wi-Fi thing in it it does yeah
Google it plays music
no it's just a ambient light it's got a
lighting effect today rushes through its
the value of this record value is only
three on the planet so
what makes it so funny because I just
wait in this thing I can feel it like
let's so it fiberglass hull core inside
thank you let's try to do the wall so
there's three of these in the world
I've got about nine of those holding one
of the nine of these things we try to
incorporate Horrell effects and
mother-of-pearl your reinforcement in
the sword stuff with any material to
make it better for like fight scenes and
stuff like well this one's a fight with
hand feel the difference in a way off
this is Volker who's played by William
Dafoe it's his will and Ando weapon
these big suits on and they sort of
gotta be that way because they're really
under training as you can see we live a
straight first concept illustrators work
out a brief and we'll do a 3d model of
it this piece here is a 3d prototype on
one of the gums to see on the table yeah
so then we'd get that and we've molded
you said you use a 3d printer for the
different parts we use a 3d printer
obviously we have to do in part so we're
good two centimeters squared for a space
we'll combine those into one piece and
then mold that and make a big fat mold
all Jason's really keen on stuff he
likes stuff I want to try to get in
there the tone for what I was playing in
Justice League and I think James has
completely changed what he wanted to do
with his character - I mean we're trying
to bridge that gap but Jays definitely
wants it a lot more a lot more levity
and fun a lot more humor and it so I
don't think you see a lot of that and
just like yeah I mean might as a lot of
smartass comments I think there's a
little bit more levity in this one
okay guys are even more I'd say that
yeah for which one yeah well I mean
Batman Superman Batman Batman Superman
those one was like a half hour that
didn't work at all so he got rid of that
it would just fall off I fought and
stuff so I want to say and what he looks
like cuz it was how do we dress up
Aquaman when he's not in his outfit
right you know he's not gonna be in a
pole yeah so cool being in a taller
boy's father and so we had him in a lot
of pulled army stuff or old military
lived out of his bag he's bit of a
wander
a loner so anything that he can keep in
his bag and his family military stuff so
kind of little bit of rock and roll or
to carried all his little jewelry and
stuff from all people he's met I'm not
offering some little tribes and things
that he's got a lot of shrinkage window
queens so that's the whole point is that
we're not we haven't gone the Trident
yet so it's just kind of what everyone
has down there that weapon is something
that a lot of the Atlantean soldiers
have but the actual Kings tried it the
one that could cut superman' slash the
one that yes it's a cut Superman flesh
oh oh yeah we looked at a lot of colors
and textures and shapes and came up with
the idea of a building block this is our
basic building block for almost every
costume shape these are mother-of-pearl
tiles but everything has an iridescent
was handmade and hand painted and hand
applied we made all our own fabric we
wanted it to have a scale in fact that
when it those are really cool did a
favorite costume you made for the film
so far
wait well you know everyone every time
we make a big costume I think it's my
one of my favorites but we have so many
of them they all becoming a favorite at
some point what's the charity no
thinking the cartoon was amazing old is
inspiring Aquaman's or Jeff chimera
what's your first shot if that has been
driven by how Jason you know is you know
he's like a kind of a
guy it's like an old night he's got that
physicality about him we're trying to
use that under the water when he moves
he's not poletik in any way like he's
very aggressive in his movement we
wanted to keep that in his costume
[Music]
you're gonna see you're gonna see that
in there too or this emerging point
where VR is consumer accessible you can
buy one of these for a couple hundred
bucks 3 Anna's the studio and I'm doing
design as we always would but taking to
that next level now and you can see
inside the set I'm with Benjamin
Donnelly who helped design the Manta
ship yes okay and I'm gonna take
everyone you show yeah she's good the
controls headphones so man has got
headphones
he's got scuba gear over here in a
window scenic view this set actually
came about through VR so we designed to
modeled it we're actually making design
decisions inside the set to essentially
turn it into what it is now it's just a
way to get the designers into the design
and essentially you know builder ask the
right questions usually you do renders
which are like oh yeah one guy does a
lot of work we actually walked around
with James on the set with one looking
just not talking about one camera shorts
which is essentially to change things
he's got a cockpit thing over here and
he's got fans and whose tickets hot
during the summer is some water use in
the corner yeah where does he keep his
frozen burritos you kind of get the idea
of how he came from concept to what it's
gonna be in the film and it's a constant
sort of back and forth process and yeah
really exciting to be able use digital
sort of tools like this
how are you nice to meet you I'm from
Los Angeles all right yeah it's like a
safety net yeah good questions ask James
Wan my first question that I was
thinking was what if we merge Fast and
Furious with Aquaman those two worlds
combined make sense fast Aquaman that's
aqua exactly or the conjuring universe
interact per man yeah that's a good
question the walther under warranty to
houses underwater conjuring yeah or
underwater saw that not be torture that
would be amazed they would be like a
really violent act oh man yes not only
to watch but to shoot as well exactly
yeah
the Chinese torture chamber but a blood
would just float so it eventually
everything will just be Brad you just
hear sound effects and things happening
but it's all in red and it'll be
artistic should probably not pitch that
idea to him good back and forth they had
their it was is that it Courtney that
was that was 16 minutes and 40 seconds I
know but it was pretty epic like I was
engaged the whole time I was really
exciting seeing all behind scenes and
the questions were great yeah brother I
gotta tell you really really well done
Courtney sat down I was like hey have
you seen Jackie's Aquaman video she's
like no I haven't yet I was like cool I
would see yet either he wants me to
check it out and then we saw the length
and we were like oh boy we really want
to do this
that really flew by yeah I lost or or
thinking about her things or thing this
is dress I was oh I was thoroughly
engaged in the whole time like the way
it was set up I loved like you said it
like the you know breaking up the
interview so they wasn't just all
talking you know yeah I don't I wouldn't
have thought about that but that act
yeah it was really smart to split up the
interview over the video is that way
because it's like you want to hear all
that yeah that's all at one chunky you
might get a little dull or boring or
slowly watching someone talk especially
like hearing on different questions from
other yeah bloggers may have been hard
to follow but it the way it was
structured was perfect I was very I was
like really impressed you got along
pretty well too I mean you look
comfortable oh I know I look comfortable
like well my favorite was the Peter Pan
thing like when he was doing what I
respect
yeah the wire effect that was really
cool yeah I'm painful especially the
spin you know the way they you still did
it and made it look graceful well that
was all his martial arts skills coming
into handy there I know
ballet I think he's a little bit about
all this like balance definitely like
dancing like yeah what if I don't know
if you did or didn't but like to have
that background I definitely would have
loved to see know some of the other
people yeah thank you see if they were
as graceful he did you a 16 so it makes
sense
yeah handstand
a couple Teresa to be showing off like
okay talented I would have liked to
seeing him laugh at some cuz he's a
great laugh like when you're really
getting to like honestly like I really
really find something funny maybe he was
having fun there yeah like even getting
to see all the the scenes after having
seen Aquaman knowing exactly where they
are what just happened
yeah it was really exciting makes you
appreciate the movie even more
especially like all the work they went
into it like you know yeah
the weapons of like how like they added
like the mother-of-pearl accidents and
things like that like Nicole Kidman's
costume was my favorite yeah
the elements that those little
meticulous things that you would never
really think would be important but they
made the whole costume design just like
the idea of the fish scales and how like
that was the basis for like the suit of
armor
well the funny thing about Aquaman is
that it gets so much flak sometimes for
being like oh it's just the CGI fast
when you really break it down it's all
CGI blended with a lot of actual like
practical built stuff you know I feel
like there's so much to appreciate
beyond just going it's a cool CGI I'm
like no there's a lot of people that
work tonight in this film absolutely
deserves so much credit it was beautiful
to watch the CG didn't take me out no it
actually invited me in I felt like I was
part of this world and I gotta say like
I can only imagine being in that tent
when you see interviews of this guy he
just seems like such a chill guy yeah
you got to think about that environment
of just like it's like this little
meeting in a tent you know super open to
all the questions at no point in time
did he give an answer that you know
either made someone feel like you know
their question was important to him
everything was important and all the
information that he shared he shared
from a place of like respect and
investment and love and joy of like the
work that he's doing and and I love to
hear about how he felt when he moons axe
Nider like approached him about being
Aquaman for the first time especially as
an actor like when you're having a
meeting with someone that you go and
you're going in blind you have nothing
no idea what to expect you go in like
kind of prepared I love that he talked
about the character that he thought he
was there for he thought he was there
for going and to then have them
presented in this different way
anyway Jabby that is your birth name yes
yep congratulations on going on set I am
proud of you I guess I'm not resentful
my jealous envious
okay just gotta block those feelings and
hope it goes away one day I hope to go
to the set of Aquaman 2 that's what
we're hoping for
that's what I'm hoping for yeah I feel
like I can only positively attract that
if I can let go I wasn't invited to the
set of Aquaman 1 but you know there's
gonna be album in two there's still time
I got you know I need W P's approval
we're here for you WB we're here for you
subscribe to the real rejects click
notification bells as they do something
on YouTube Courtney right that's
Kourtney without you but she does love
you like that I wrote that down before
you showed up Courtney right follow her
on Instagram and Twitter go to jab eco a
channel he could really use the boost
and subscribers write the video you know
now you're just saw here I mean you did
you did he watched it with us we were a
family we enjoyed it together but you
know
[Music]